wir sind hier im lesesaal der
schweizerischen nationalbibliothek und
sprechen ein bisschen leid und zwar mit
der direktorin aus diesem hause dass
marie christin dürfe ich habe hier ein
beispiel mit bewachte ich möchte
herausfinden wo sind ihre grenzen des
archivieren science ein infoblatt zum
thema neu sei von der schule zurecht
würden sie das archivieren
leider werden wir das nicht auch sie
werden grundsätzlich auch die wehren wie
oder sammeln wir dokumenten ab sechs
seiten mit einer mindest auflage von 50
exemplare das wird doch nicht unsere
sammlung gehören wie demokratisch
behandeln sie dann ihre schätze wenn wir
jetzt zwei beispiele nennen ein sehr
hoch graben das literarisches dokument
von einem ganz unbekannten
schriftsteller aus dem feld stand und
ein werbeplakat aus den 50er jahren also
wir sammeln alles was in der schweiz
produziert wird das ist die unsere
allgemeine sammlung seit 1848 und dann
exemplarische bild dokument aus der
schweizer bevölkerung ihre
persönlichkeit und archiv und nachlässe
von schweizerisch schweizer autorinnen
und autoren nur fünf prozent dieses
riesigen archiv wird genuss darum ist
diese zahl so tief das ist ein normaler
so für nationalbibliotheken und deswegen
versuchen wir auch die dokumente und
mieter digitalisierung näher zu den
kunden zu bringen
vor fünf jahren sie sprechen dann haben
sie mit der digitalen archivierung
begonnen
im gegensatz zum original auf papier
weiß man aber gar nicht was mit diesen
elektronischen datenträgern passieren
ist das nicht eine unsichere sache mit
der langzeitarchivierung stellen sicher
und mit digitalen dokumente andere
herausforderung das ist richtig wir
müssen die lesbarkeit auch für die
zukunft sicherstellen
und da haben wir es noch nicht im griff
das heißt wie nicht nur der us
nationalbibliothek alle bibliotheken
sind im moment ab suchen so wie wir
diese lesbarkeit und zusicherung der
inhalte sicherstellen können